all right welcome everybody it is
the end and the beginning it's
inauguration day
for president joe biden donald trump has
already left washington dc and we are
counting down
to the um actual swearing-in of joe
biden expected to happen
just after noon eastern time so we've
got about an hour and 40 minutes
the festivities of course will start far
sooner than that
they will be reduced in size and scope
because of the coronavirus pandemic
and that is okay that is okay donald
trump flying out
early this morning giving some deranged
statements um including saying have a
nice life
to his supporters and we will look at
clips of that momentarily but
what a day we have today um the biden
administration which does not yet exist
but soon will
has a very big day planned and in fact
joe biden is expected to sign
actually let's see i can show you the
schedule this is
important stuff um this is the biden
schedule as you can see
um 11 15 the swearing-in ceremony will
start the actual swearing-in can't
happen until noon and then we will have
that
and then later today you will see that
at
um 5 15 president biden will
then president biden will be signing
some executive orders and taking other
presidential actions
at 7 00 p.m we will have our first press
briefing by press secretary jen sackey
there hasn't been a serious press
briefing by the trump administration for
months other than that
90-second delusion by kaylee mcinanni
a few weeks ago seven tonight we will
have a
press briefing from gen saki and we will
hear presumably about all of the orders
signed by biden at 5 15 many of which
will
undo the atrocities done by donald trump
and then at 8 48 pm we're scheduled to
hear
remarks an inauguration set of remarks
from
biden and kamala and then at 9 55 pm
eastern time
on the east coast 6 55 pm on the west
coast
the president and first lady will appear
on the blue room balcony another
tradition of inauguration day so there
will be
a lot going on today i don't know how
much of it i will cover
um but certainly i will be back maybe
for the press briefing
as well as the nighttime stuff i mean
why not right this only happens every
four years so
many many things to cover and to discuss
today um we at some point i would also
love to squeeze in
uh phone calls if it's possible our goal
there's no more poetic goal than 306
today the number of electoral votes with
which joe biden
uh won this presidential election so
much to discuss and it will be very
very compelling i see all of these thank
yous coming in via super chat and i love
it as we see oh god is that ted cruz
uh looks sort of like ted cruz um
the vegan villainess thanking me for
getting us through the insane presidency
and jessica thanking from queensland
australia
james wants a recap of the last four
years yeah that would take uh that that
would take a long time to do we're not
equipped to do that
right now but certainly we will be
recapping many different
elements of the last uh many years for
sure
no doubt about that yeah that is ted
cruz and he
he just looks like somebody you can't
trust
no question about it no question
whatsoever
earlier this morning if you want to take
a quick look donald trump
um speaking melania also spoke briefly
take a listen
being your first lady was my greatest
honor
thank you for your love and your support
you will be in my thoughts and prayers
god bless you all
god bless your families and as you can
see an extremely powerful and passionate
speech from the least popular first lady
in the history of polling uh melania
trump
donald trump then saying um wait where
was it here
donald trump basically his police clap
moment saying remember if anything good
happens in the future it was thanks to
my doing you're going to see
incredible numbers start coming in if
everything is
sort of left alone be careful very
complex
it's really complicated guys if biden
does nothing things will be good thanks
to trump
but you're going to see some incredible
things happening
and remember us when you see these
things happen right
think of trump when biden does things
that seem good remember us because
i'm looking at i'm looking at elements
of our economy that are set to be
a rocket ship up it's a rocket ship up
yep very strong elements of
economics i can barely put it together
here is trump saying we've left it all
on the field
i think you're going to see those
numbers really skyrocket downward
and i can only say this we have worked
hard
we've left it all as the athletes would
say we've left it all in the field
we don't have to
we don't have to come and say we'll
never say in
a month when we're sitting in florida
we're
not going to be worried about each other
and saying you know if we only worked a
little bit harder you can
well if you had only dealt with the
pandemic you'd be having another four
years
trump again mentioning the china virus
china virus
it's a uh horrible thing that was
put onto the world we all know where it
came from but it's a horrible horrible
thing
so be very careful be very very careful
but
careful we want to pay should have said
be careful back in february
uh great love great love to all of the
people that have suffered including
families who have suffered so gravely
so i guess it's good he's mentioning the
victims of the virus and then again
trump mentioning the 1917 flu pandemic
which didn't start until 1918.
put it in a position like it's never
been before despite the worst plague to
hit since i guess you'd say
1917 over a hundred years ago
right okay so that was 1918 we still
don't know why he does that
and then here trump uh his final
send-off
have a good life as uh indistinguishable
from satire unable to be parodied why
mca starts as if this is some kind of
victory rally
the things that we've done have been
just incredible
and i couldn't have done them done it
without you so just
a goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form
please now
and again uh i wanted just in
living i want to thank our vice
president mike pence and karen
i want to thank congress because we
really worked well with congress
at least certain elements of congress
elements but we really did we've gotten
so much done that nobody thought would
be possible but i do want to thank
congress and i want to thank all of the
great people of washington d.c
all of the people that we worked with to
put this miracle together
so have a good life we will see you soon
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much
can you imagine
anyway so that's donald trump's final
screed as president of the united states
and breaking with tradition the first uh
healthy president in 110 to the extent
he's healthy
in 152 years to skip
the inauguration of their successor
and there it is that was not a saturday
night live skit but that was very
very real uh i want to say a huge thank
you
to the nine people who just grabbed
twitch subscriptions
uh i i so appreciate your support and
everybody's support
um and also a very very special thank
you to delia
wolff who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
we do have a very modest goal we want to
match the number of electoral votes
secured
by uh president-elect biden 306
we've got 10 and i invite you that this
is a new beginning it's a new
start and i would love it if you signed
up at joinpakman.com
using this coupon code that is a uh a
signal to a better future starting today
better 21
is the coupon code the discount's so big
i can't even put it on the screen
it would be in nice to interview robert
reich for his take on trump and his
presidency says james he is welcome on
the program anytime
we've not had success getting him on
thank you all at the pacman show for
keeping us sane p.s i wouldn't buy a
used car
from ted cruz well said well said
uh we are seeing the uh
this is the real caravan not the
guatemalan one coming through mexico
to the southern border that doesn't
exist this is the actual caravan
bringing the very soon to be president
of the united states joseph r biden jr
over to the capitol um all calm there
have been about a dozen national guard
folks
removed from their detail uh due to
risks of a possible insider conflict of
of loyalty let's put it that way there
was also a guy with fake
credentials with a gun and ammo
arrested on friday trying to get into
the
uh restricted area so there have been
some of these uh elements that have
taken place
but for the most part i expect that this
is going to be
no problem whatsoever i think security
is going to have it all handled
very very well and we look forward to it
we will soon see
a number of dignitaries including joe
biden himself
the president-elect and it is all
happening it feels like just yesterday
that donald trump was being inaugurated
it feels like a decade has gone by
since then and yet it also feels like it
went by in a flash in some other ways uh
very very difficult to sort of have one
say this is the way it feels it has felt
quick and it has felt
uh long at different points in time i
think is the only way that that i can
say it
delia ann wolfe says you pronounce my
name beautifully
even my dog heard my name on the tv
i appreciate that delia i always do the
best i can to pronounce everybody's
everybody's names correctly uh there is
president-elect joe biden with a
remember secret and president vice
president-elect kamala harris
with the soon-to-be second gentleman
douglas
emhoff um the first uh who will be the
first
jewish uh president vice president or
spouse thereof
ever joe biden only the second catholic
in history to be president of the united
states
john f kennedy of course the first and
you may start to see it's tough with
masks but you will start to see
some secret service agents who may look
familiar and the reason they will look
familiar is they were folks that worked
with the obama biden administration
um unusual that you will see a full
replacement
of the secret service detail for a new
president
typically you see some folks you would
expect to see folks from the trump
administration
a secret service detail go and work with
biden
due to fears of trump loyalists and
anti-masters
it is a fully replaced detail which we
talked about
on the program a couple of weeks ago
another first
that you don't typically need to worry
about uh
but they they need to be very careful
because of potential trump loyalists
in all of these areas and it is a very
good thing
it is a very very good thing uh that
they are doing that you cannot be too
cautious i believe this is amy klobuchar
and her husband senator amy klobuchar
and her husband
joe biden as well as jill biden kamala
harris actually that that may be
sort of looks like roy blunt maybe
that's not amy klobuchar's husband
with masks it's hard to tell um
there is doug imhoff and uh amy
klobuchar
soon to be first lady jill biden also
other firsts as i talked oh sorry hold
on
i'm missing aditya balasubramanian
has just signed up at joinpakman.com
apologies in advance if i didn't get
that name quite right
matthew dill also grabbing a
subscription at 12
dill one of my favorite herbs there's
really
few things better than than dill absent
dill
you can use fennel greens
fennel fronds i think i would say as a
reasonable replacement to dill
another first donald trump leaving
office as the least popular president in
the polling era
averaging 41 never reaching 50
and leaving with a low of 29. so trump
the least popular president ever
melania trump the least popular first
lady ever in the polling era as well
and let's see if we can get a little
audio here
that's just just for the ambiance
so many many firsts my friends many
firsts and i can't imagine that that
will be the
end of it stock markets reacting
positively today to what is going on
we are very excited to see the
acceleration of vaccination take place
and you will notice that donald trump's
absence
i'm not really feeling it in any way
that i find negative i'm fine with
donald trump
probably being very close to landing in
uh palm beach
florida i think that that is the right
place for donald trump it is not here
uh not not by any means david have you
ever played or enjoyed card games like
magic the gathering i have not i don't
like i don't like magic the gathering
joe biden is going to be the 46th
president of the united states
says radcat that is true that is
absolutely true
a princess juggs says via twitch sub
love the content keep up the good work
thank you and thanks to the 19 folks who
just grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions a very very special day
here
and a lot going on as we see the
president-elect
enter the u.s capitol there is nancy
pelosi
hard to identify people with the masks
but i'm confident that was nancy pelosi
and this is going to build over the next
so here's the schedule there's 45
more minutes until the the inauguration
ceremony starts
the actual swearing-in will be at noon
and that is that is by law
uh the the president is president until
noon
eastern and then it will be joe biden
here is a look from the other side of
the capitol
and there is a lot happening here we did
cover the pardons we
recorded today's podcast bright and
early
so the podcast that will go live in a
couple of hours is a pre-inauguration
podcast we covered pardons
we covered donald trump's final uh
screeds
and then tomorrow's podcast we will have
you know inauguration related stuff
trust the plan says optimistically
cynical yeah i started getting messages
this is so funny
we we were getting messages up until
about a week ago that would say trump
2020.
now i'm getting messages from these
people who still think there's some
grand plan for trump to remain president
and they're saying
trump 2021 something now is going
they've moved the goal post
they believe something will happen
during 2021 to bring trump
back tom denny with a very
powerful meaningful inspirational super
chat
tom with a 75 blockbuster says
i voted for the first time in my life
partly because of you thank you so much
david a very
important message tom i really
appreciate that
and you love to hear it that's the
that's the importance of alternatives to
corporate media we've never
it it has never been more important than
now
i do want to say thank you to a few
other uh
subscribers that just signed up at
joinedpakman.com this
what what is important to me about
seeing people signing up today
is that uh clearly people get that this
is only the beginning
we've only now gotten the ball back
we're about to
and even this afternoon joe biden will
start with the executive orders and it's
going to be a process
big thank you to matt fisher as well as
joanne
tarkong thanks to nikki
levi as well as jake dorazio
thanks to benjamin finley and ramsey
buress
big thank you to adrian abeda and
william mitchell
and lastly adley teague has signed up i
appreciate the nine of you who have
grabbed a membership
yes if you're wondering the coupon code
better 21 refers directly to what we're
seeing today
it is the oh and there is mitt romney uh
willard
m romney uh oh a little mask removal
there very aggressive
very very aggressive mask pull down uh
but yes mitt romney attending
strong turnout from both republicans
and democrats here selfies are going
by the way is the audio mix okay guys do
i need to turn the background noise up
or down i don't want to
i don't want it to be uh please direct
your attention
toward the inaugural platform
oh okay i don't know that many of you
care about the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff
audio mix is good okay good very good
very good can you connect website
memberships to
twitch or discord not to twitch but yes
on discord message them the discord mods
show them a screenshot of your website
membership and then you will get a very
special member
tag on the discord very exciting
hi dave any expectation of violence
around the country today
yeah i think that there will be oh god
it's lindsay there will be some attempts
at violence
but i hope that it will be quelled and
ineffective
but i do i i do think there will be some
attempts at violence for sure
and i don't take any pleasure in that
thanks for your coverage this morning
happy to be with you on this celebratory
day
absolutely uh it feels like some good is
finally around the corner been waiting
four years for this
yeah we've been waiting a long time
we've been waiting a long time
uh is that steve scalise is that who
that is i can't tell
i thought steve scalise was a little
thinner maybe
yeah i don't know but in any case
welcome welcome welcome to all we are
live on youtube twitch and facebook i
really appreciate everybody being here
we're also live on the free speech tv
facebook page
uh which i uh which we love we
appreciate that
uh i did make an appearance last night
an impromptu appearance on the live
stream of uh steve
of cuban-american stephen kenneth
destiny
bonnell the second um okay closed
captions we'll get closed captions on at
people's request
very nice um
could we try to start saying ivanka's
instead of karen's thanks for keeping us
sane david have a good life that's not
bad i don't i don't dislike that that's
not a bad idea
um as a disabled veteran and single
father trump has been the worst thing
for this nation i had to pay for visits
and meds thanks to trump
i can barely survive as it is but now we
finally actually have hope
start the heal says hayden kaji
says as an australian i'm glad we have
less pressure to push conservative in
the future
here's hoping for a new deal thanks for
your hard work and perseverance yeah
the work starts now my friends the work
starts now
hayden says today feels like a
countrywide sobering cup of coffee after
a three-day drinking binge hangover
nice analogy we made it
republican the honorable stephen scalise
the honorable james
e cliver scalise and clyburn coming in
the country may be in shambles but we
made it looking forward to boring news
live streams again
now that trump is gone will certain
trumpian elements of language very
powerfully leave you it could be
tremendous like no one's ever seen
couldn't say it better myself couldn't
possibly say it better myself
some might say we have been biden our
time nice
cole must be a dad now is not the time
to go to sleep or take a break now
is the time to get active the next four
years is
ours yes a lot of
very important considerations there
i believe was that patrick leahy senator
patrick leahy this is clyburn here of
course
there's scalise
tough to identify a lot of different
people
big thank you to nathaniel jordan
as well as nine other people who just
grabbed twitch prime subscriptions i do
very much appreciate that
and uh oh my god i've fallen way behind
on
joined pacman thank yous yeah it's a
very special day on our website
joinedpakman.com
thanks to rob bessler and nathaniel
jordan
jason seep and quentin boatwright
big thank you to enrico gambi and nathan
langdon janine fisher has signed up so
has ryan lobb wow these are just massive
dumps of membership stephanie frana
and julio ortiz as well as tara dibble
11 new members very much appreciate that
also thanks to jack quantum for gifting
10. people in a celebratory mood today
because there are a lot of things
happening big thank you to
jacob for a hundred dollar super chat
just simply with the message woot bay
photo
not a mega cap in sight isn't that a
pleasant
uh visual image that if this were
trump's reinauguration we would be
seeing a sea
of those stupid red maga hats and kaga
hats
and uh wow i'm being told of a bomb
threat at the capitol let's see
bomb threat not finding it right now let
me see if i can find
an article about that
bomb threat
u.s supreme court being evacuated due to
a bomb
threat yes indeed supreme court public
information officer
says a bomb threat was called into the
court but the building has not been
evacuated breaking
gentlemen leadership of the united
states senate
president pro tempore emeritus the
honorable patrick leahy
and mrs marshall leahy democratic whip
the honorable dick durbin and mrs
remaden
majority whip the honorable john thune
and mrs kimberly thune
democratic leader the honorable charles
schumer and mrs irish weinshall schumer
and president pro-tempore of the senate
the honorable chuck grassley and mrs
jennifer high
there it is um yes
sources confirm a bomb threat at the
supreme court but conflicting reports as
to whether it was evacuated
here is charles schumer and his wife
entering
and there is chuck grassley presumably
recovered from
the virus and now able to be here
very much happening very very much
happening
[Music]
and importantly so as folks continue to
file in
if you're just joining us the expected
schedule is
the ceremony starts at 11 15 a.m in
about a half hour
and the actual swearing-in happens at
the stroke
of noon eastern time in about an hour
and 19
minutes that's the schedule we
expect
wish it was bernie but glad it's not
trump i'm getting involved with
progressive activism in my community
don't want to get
lulled into complacency love your
content david greetings from austria
honestly what happened in the u.s
reminds me of my country's history
beans says smash that like button thank
you david for your hard work
oscar says massive dumps of david pakman
discounts thanks david
stephen says the circus finally left the
white house what a beautiful day
ej says david what happens to the
lincoln project now
who cares i don't know i mean i assume
they just go back to being regular
republicans
uh today's the end in less than this is
tisha mcdonald
today's the end in less than 90 minutes
45
will no longer be relevant in our minds
as the mad wannabe dictator we will be
free from his divisive rhetoric media
trolling and temper tantrums
i don't know that we will be free from
it but at least he won't be the
president anymore
unknown says too many septigenerians we
need
young people young people
yes many people uh
coming to that conclusion after seeing
some of the demographics
of uh those in leadership very very much
true
[Music]
and a lot of warm-up music happening
here
cheering in champaign from stockholm
sweden
how much do we have to here to to pay to
hear david sing the national anthem
here's to turning the page
yeah i don't know that we can get enough
memberships for that gooney has
subscribed with twitch prime and says
you're the best enjoying the show time
to heal starts now greetings from
germany
yes i've been hearing from many of our
german
viewers very very pleased with what is
going on
as we speak stocks going absolutely
bananas
and we have to be careful about drawing
causal conclusions there big thank you
though i was in the process of saying
thanks to the additional 21 people who
just signed up via twitch
putting us at 82 and also a few other
people to thank on joinpakman.com
i don't want to miss anybody claire
manganon just signed up on my website
joe frye just signed up jasper groot
has signed up oliver yarid
has a new membership angela hamar
and jack hughes putting together some
some nice numbers there
we are expecting very very soon
that uh a procession of former
presidents will enter
as you see traditional grip being
applied there by the snare drummers
dan quayle wow how old is dan quayle now
that's interesting
dan quayle is now 73 years old former
vice president to george
h.w bush that's an h
as in white and um
not known as a particularly smart guy in
fact often ridiculed much the way george
w bush was but there is dan quayle
saying hello to a number of different
people did i did i see kellyanne
conway's daughter posted a tick tock of
kellyanne hitting her last night i did
not
i did not let's see
[Music]
claudia conway tick-tock
post-disturbing tick-tock showing mom
hitting her yikes
wow yeah i mean we're not gonna we're
not gonna do that right now but
that sounds pretty pretty bonkers
greetings from your neighbor up north
very happy with biden rejecting the
pipeline we respect the land of our
indigenous people
here's a message in spanish from andres
who says
which means finally the day is here
thanks david for your work
i wouldn't have been able to make it
without you beautiful message
beautiful beautiful spanish message
david where's the salmon
shirt oh uh i put it in the fridge with
some haddock and cod
i work with right wingers god help me
yeah vince it's gonna be a tough it's
gonna be tough
it's gonna be tough for a little while
no doubt about that the deficit and
pandemic deaths are now the worst thing
ever in history on fox news and newsmax
wait for it
yeah so joe biden's scheduled to be
sworn in at 12th
at 1205 you will hear about how uh every
coronavirus death is joe biden's fault
[Music]
that is what we are expecting big thank
you to matt lapresti
for signing up at joinpacman.com regine
hertelu nian
narine i'm struggling with some of these
names danielle watts of course
adam weston and chris salden
also a thank you to sherry bowling
putting us
at uh 95 95 oh my goodness there's three
more these will just not stop dumping in
jean lee has signed up howard chen
and raw miller or r.a miller putting us
at 98.
um there is former president william
jefferson clinton and hillary rodham
clinton
reportedly hillary not bringing any
bleached hard drives with her
not hiding any emails not stuffing any
paper trails
into her pant suit just showing up
to see the swearing-in
of joe biden former president bill
clinton and hillary clinton arriving
here
somehow she managed to avoid prison for
the last four years you know it's
it was looking pretty tough there for a
second i mean okay there was no
investigation or possibility of charges
or charges being investigated or charges
drawn up
or charges predicted or charges
announced or anything
but it really looked tough for a second
there that she might end up locked up as
so many
so-called populist right-wingers wanted
to see
and uh we will soon presumably see
george w bush and laura bush arrive as
well as barack h obama and michelle
obama
a lot happening here a lot happening
here
david hope it's a good morning on your
end how does it feel knowing you no
longer have to cover the antics of the
stale chicken nugget trump i'm looking
forward to it
and by the way tomorrow on the show
i've been preparing this for a couple of
days
frank luntz did a um
focus group with some trumpists to
figure out
like how you could deprogram them and
it's really scary
really really scary people are telling
me the joe biden
facebook stream is really good and it
has some behind the scenes things
the honorable william j clinton and the
honorable hillary
there is george w bush i think we may
keep it here for now just not to be
flipping back and forth between things
there is bill clinton
hillary clinton
participating doing their best to keep
this a peaceful transfer of power
despite donald trump's
absolutely best intentions uh thanks to
the 20 folks who just grabbed twitch
subs i appreciate that including great
people like here we go
avinar johnny marv short brief
dedrick and splatterakes as we see
george w bush and laura bush
arrive as well fist bumps
from george w bush who has become
close friends with the obamas over the
last several years
there we have james clyburn speaking to
who is he speaking to who's the guy in
the white hair whose face is blocked i
can't quite tell
oh it's bill clinton bill clinton there
a lot happening here as we build
to the swearing-in of joe biden
beautiful
traditional grip snare drum technique
happening
you really couldn't ask for better
better traditional grip on that left
hand there
here is former president barack obama
and former first lady michelle
obama who still enjoys approval ratings
that
um really make melania trump look very
bad
and as i mentioned earlier uh melania
trump uh and donald trump leaving
office with the lowest approval ratings
in history
in the polling era before i mean listen
in 1820 maybe there was somebody less
popular but we wouldn't know it
we didn't have modern polling of course
soon barack obama will enter the united
states
and uh don't worry guys we'll we'll get
the audio i'm gonna have perfect audio
once this actually starts these are just
announcements of the people coming in
and we can tell who this is
this is george w bush with a
very windy entrance as you can see laura
bush as well
and many many people on the left and
right happy to see donald trump finally
go
[Music]
that's not dick cheney is it that wasn't
dick cheney
or was it i mean i don't know see this
guy right is that cheney oh i think it
might be dick chain
the war criminal contingent entering at
this point in time
clearly an illuminati symbol on michelle
obama's belt yes exactly
did pence and ivanka attend the
inauguration ivanka isn't even invited
i heard the funniest thing there was
like an announcement made that ivanka
will not be attending
i'm not aware that ivanka was invited uh
very strange but mike pence will be here
he is expected to be here yeah
[Music]
great pronunciation of my name earlier
yes regine
herdelu just subscribed on twitch on
your website been a fan for a while no
better day than today to join thank you
for being great no thank you regine
i appreciate that people are asking if
the member count is accurate
it is not it is not somehow i got 11.88
it is 118.
but let's make it even more accurate um
the 44th president of the united states
the announcement of barack obama
and mrs michelle obama big thank you to
ellen meschenberg thanks ellen for the
sub
also thanks to matt axelson
adrian trogler big thank you to
rasheed idrissi dustin wagner
and tara steno very much appreciate that
[Applause]
it is it really is a special day we i
mean it's it's in the coupon code
better21
we're starting and looking for a better
21 here's barack obama greeting chuck
schumer
and james clyburn this to me feels like
the type of event where lindsey graham
would try to like interject into the the
handshakes between people who like each
other and kind of you'd see him in the
back
sort of like trying to get a handshake
from someone and people
not too thrilled with lindsay's presence
and there is michelle obama steve
scalise there speaking to george w
bush or not really maybe speaking to
laura bush more than anything else
after bringing a confederate flag into
the capital can the republican party
still call themselves the party of
lincoln well
they were calling some calling
themselves that regardless
of the supreme court supreme court
filing in
here is the supreme court led by chief
justice
john roberts
followed by looks like sonia sotomayor
correct me if i'm wrong i believe that
sonia sotomayor
elena kagan then neil gorsuch
this is tougher with the masks
lunatic brett kavanaugh and then
the absolutely disgusting amy covid
barrett
known for the super spreader event
there's john roberts
[Music]
yikes this is some pretty vile stuff not
gonna lie
[Music]
you look happy david feeling what we are
all feeling a collective sigh of relief
yeah listen there is a sigh of relief
that trump is gone
and yet we know that now is when now is
when it starts
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now we are getting to some of the
kids of the different uh folks
and we are building building building
howard stern apparently doing the uh
public address as you could as you could
hear some people noticing that that's a
joke by the way
that's a joke can't wait to see how many
political events trump won't be invited
to
yeah i've spoken about this before the
trump family is about to
re-enter a world where the social
circles that they
uh just barely qualified for four years
ago are going to reject them in great in
great uh
significant degree and that's going to
be um
i guess tough for them but who cares
look at that lunatic brett kavanaugh
what a disgusting person
horrifying that he's even involved in
government really really bad
just absolutely horrible there's amy
kovet barrett
newest supreme court justice of course
hopefully she will have absolutely no
role to play
in this yeah it's this is a mix of
horror and joy because we're reminded of
all of the lunatics that are still
involved in government
and that's a very scary thing my wife
had her first baby appointment today and
i couldn't join because of kovid
and our lame president i had to watch
her tear up as she walked in
only saving grace is that trump is
finally done let's move on please yes
and congratulations on the new baby
anytime i see w now all i can think of
is are you wearing your big boy shirt
from that bad lip reading video of
trump's inauguration
this feels like when the munchkins sing
ding dong the witch is dead
oh here we have more i believe these are
some of biden's uh
grandkids and let's see who is this is
that hunter
a lot of very interesting people here
um oh sorry i know i'm falling behind
thanks to
mary grabhorn as well as veronica
zerdeva
amy trudeau and jose
carlos aguilar pass
new members at joinpackman.com putting
us at 132.
also thanks to ryan and two and cora
bikini
and uh candy soda pop in and all these
different people
uh via twitch very much appreciate it
more biden family arriving
and remember for people confused about
the schedule it
is now almost 11 a.m in the east 8 a.m
in the west
the ceremony starts at 11 15 the
swearing in itself
at noon at noon
and there you see neil gorsuch amy kovet
barrett and brett kavanaugh
sonia sotomayor here there's john
roberts
very important day uh donald trump
missing but not noticeably absent that's
the way i'm i'm putting it
missing but not noticeably and absent we
are better off without him there
yeah so this is hunter biden and ashley
biden
people wondering where's hunter well
he's right there
uh no laptops on him um
period i don't know where i was going
with that
but there is hunter bide i wonder how
many times during this trump will pick
up his phone to tweet and think oh wait
there is uh barack obama filing in
wow what a day really what a day
uh welcome to everybody it is the top of
the hour um i'm so glad you're joining
us there is vice president mike pence
and
his uh karen his wife sorry uh that was
a freudian slip
mike pence and his wife karen um
and they are here period
and i don't think there's that much else
to say about it
we are 15 minutes from the start of the
inauguration ceremony in about 45
minutes from a new president
45 minutes from officially donald trump
being
a former president former president
and yes let's go to a 20-minute ad break
starting now
i'm kidding i wouldn't do that to you
guys i would not do that
um there is mike pence though in in all
seriousness filing in
congrats to all americans says josepha
you made it so happy to have you back
dem studio says would you collab with
beau of the fifth column
sure yeah sure if he was interested in
that
david trump's daughter wanted to go with
her husband but when trump heard she was
going to go trump told her she couldn't
and she backed off no loss there
yeah we need ivanka trump out out of
anything relating to government
and i fear she may try to get back in to
be perfectly frank
i think she's desperate to get back in a
lot of
memberships happening right now i want
to say thanks to jarvis sampson for
signing up at jointpakman.com
also robert [ __ ]
nick baldwin has signed up sullivan
sizer has signed up and cheryl
white all new members at joinpakman.com
we we are starting fresh my friends the
new coupon code
better21 we're all hoping for a better
21 starting today
and this is just the beginning just the
beginning
and i invite you to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com as we will see a
transition
i can't say it's completely peaceful
because of what donald trump has done
but it will not be held up by violence
at the capitol it will not be held up
uh by any of it a little masked down
situation from a sort of ted kennedy
dead ringer uh
yes a dead ringer for ted kennedy not
ted kennedy of course the late senator
ladies and gentlemen accompanying the
vice president the secretary of the
senate
the honorable julie e adams and chief
administrative officer of the house of
representatives catherine
spindor right
yes uh a lot a lot happening as you can
see
and we are building here to the
inauguration of joe
biden we have almost total mask
compliance a few people pulling it down
and doing it more as a throat covering
like a scarf but that's okay
i am excited to be bored with biden love
from norway
thanks yeah no that's that's a good
point
i'm here for the massive dumps of
memberships became a member last year
you helped
me make it through the madness thank you
yeah massive memberships have been
dumped
throughout the day it is really
something else um
brandy woodford just dumping a
membership
dominic schmidt as well putting us at
147.
uh and we are getting very close my
friends i actually i don't remember what
they do
for 45 minutes between the start of the
ceremony
oh here we go oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the united states
the honorable michael r pence and mrs
karen pence
oh give me a break
[Music]
it's the world's biggest loser behind
only donald trump donald trump of course
presiding over
the loss of the house of representatives
republican control in 2018
the loss of senate control by
republicans in 2020
making himself a one-term president and
also one of the
worst global failures on coronavirus
second only to trump as the biggest
loser is mike pence
who remember how he was running that
coronavirus task force
that didn't go so well mike pence
shaking hands with james clyburn
with laura bush and george w bush as you
can see
very perfunctory and not particularly
warm greetings from the former
republican president
uh mike pence denounced by his own
president donald trump
on january 6 the very unusual and
bizarre event
but everything's been bizarre and
unusual quite frankly
unclear if there will be any space force
guardians of the galaxy attending today
but uh that remains to be seen david
couldn't watch this with anyone but you
thank you so much let's all bask in the
trumplessness
do you think there's any chance of the
biden administration prosecuting trump
listen joe biden should not be in any
way involved
the justice department should look at
evidence they should look at uh
complaints and they should make
determinations based on the facts that's
it
it should not be political
the enabler mr pence here he is yeah
well said very much well said
thanks to venezuelan jedi and tilapia
jack
and a 10 other folks who just grabbed
twitch subscriptions i appreciate that
very much
also thank you to uh whoa i'm i'm barely
able to keep up with the membership
dumps let me try
nicole herrera isabel bonneau
paul chown jake roberts
joanna dawn and sigurd melvay
have signed up on my website also thayer
trotter
and rhonda schminke and lastly justin
pomar
so a lot happening there um i do want to
make of an announcement i have finished
watching
season one of lupe on netflix it is one
of the best shows i've seen yes people
asking if i've seen the show it is
absolutely fantastic
and i i can't wait for season two
big thank you as well yeah i'm actually
i'm barely able to keep up so i'm gonna
we may have to get away from these thank
yous joachim holmblad
christopher garofali clarissa monica
daniel cosda has signed up alan morell
and danny chee big thank yous to all of
you very much appreciate that
uh there is debbie wasserman schultz i
think anyway i hope i'm not getting that
wrong there is george w bush near mike
pence
james clyburn in the background as you
can see
bush and pence now talking who knows
what they're talking about
does bush address that pence has been
part of
enabling one of the the most incompetent
and weaponized
administrations in history or do they
just talk about
did you see that cool psalm i don't know
i don't know
big thank you to greg robb who just
grabbed a membership appreciate that
greg
very much also thanks to cw
who is gifting subs like their water
on twitch um
another nine folks just signed up there
amazing uh the i
i predict that 2021 for us will be the
year of twitch
i think it will be a big big year for us
on twitch
uh a platform suited for the times
certainly
thanks for the coverage david much to do
but we made it through trump yeah
i'm thinking about it as now we can get
to work and that's a good thing
this we've not solved anything by
getting rid of trump but now we can
actually get to
work and that's a very very important
thing
um if you're just joining us we should
be just a few minutes away
from the start of the inauguration
ceremony the uh swearing in itself
scheduled for the top of the hour
who is that
looks vaguely familiar but i'm not sure
who that is
is that a-rod is that really alex
rodriguez that is hilarious
it's really alex rodriguez that's
amazing
what is he doing here i don't even know
um i want to say thanks to oliver wilde
for the very generous 50
super chat says david i'm very much
looking forward to this next chapter for
america and the david pakman show
it feels good to be hopeful once again
yeah
uh oh here's brian coldy my
brother-in-law by marriage
once removed love the show here is to
2021 make sure you sub
uh thank you so much colby coming in out
of nowhere with a strong
super chat great to see you adom says
love your show in the teddy stratford
shirts yeah
this is not one of those shirts as you
can see there is no there's actually
buttons the teddy stratford shirt is
known for the zipper
but this is not a teddy stratford shirt
this this
it is buttons all the way down very very
exciting stuff
it's it's shirt fraud yeah it's a
fraudulent shirt
i don't recognize these folks coming in
now to be perfectly frank
but i'm certain they're very very
important
there we do re recognize the uh moments
from being vice president kamala harris
and the soon-to-be second gentleman
douglas emhoff
um oh that was eugene goodman oh wow
that's important
that's important uh there is kamala she
will be the first
female vice president of the united
states very very exciting day
exciting in a lot of different ways
what a day what a day she will soon be
introduced
thanks to adjective pants and others for
the twitch subs
appreciate it it's so great to see
everybody here today
alex rodriguez is there because j.lo is
performing beautiful
beautiful i love it very nice
thanks to philip key for signing up on
my website chrissytzar as well
eleni papa nicholas has signed up as has
nick myers
thanks to peter e jones as well as diana
ubila
big thank you to james andrews and april
ortiz for the website
memberships angela edelkamp and lisa
thorne
and wow for rock masood and steve hoyt
what a day
uh that is that is really an incredible
day
putting us at 201. inaugural ceremonies
maria miller-lohmeyer
the acting deputy house sergeant-at-arms
kevin grubbs
and the acting deputy senate
sergeant-at-arms united states capitol
police officer private first class
eugene o
goodman nice eugene goodman there he is
um i believe the reason that there are
acting secretaries at arms is because
they the ones previously resigned over
their mishandling of the
uh trump riots on january 6th correct me
if i'm wrong
yes as many of you are noticing there is
no trump here
he is absent but not missing no sorry he
is missing but i'm not feeling his
absence
it really feels like it would be wrong
for trump to be here his presidency has
been so disgusting
um i think it's it's great that he's not
here quite frankly he would just be a
distraction
thanks to sean dawson for making a
pledge on patreon we'll count patrons
we'll count patrons towards the goal
debbie harris and mr douglas imhof here
comes the
soon-to-be vice president of the united
states kamala harris we are now getting
to it scheduled
to start in three minutes the incoming
second gentleman douglas emhoff who has
left his job to be
supportive of kamala harris's vp in his
capacity as second gentleman
it is really getting started uh mike
pence clapping now
perfunctory
[Music]
[Applause]
an historic moment a historic moment
and historic moment it is all of the
above
[Music]
wow it's happening
greeting the former president barack
obama it is happening
[Music]
wow
what a day
[Music]
the super chats people very excited
they're flying in
[Music]
buffalo asks uh i heard trump paid a
huge amount for the inaugural luncheon
catering by mcdonald's can you comment
if attendees will get multiple nugget
sauces no
uh trump is so cheap that you will
either have a barbecue or honey mustard
for the nuggets
um it's not going to be both it's one or
the other you're going to have to make
your pick
and that is it that is it
[Music]
you will have a choice a choice of sauce
that is it
trump apparently hoarding the sweet and
sour as well
big thank you to dane howell wow i'm
gonna have to run through these veronica
martinez michael harkin signed up on my
website
russ thalheimer stephen heap
[Music]
thomas brandegard
keith harrington as well as guion branch
and dane howell wow incredible what's
happening
also big thanks to the 11 additional
twitch subscribers putting us at 2
20. people responding and very rapidly
going to 306 which is the number of
electoral votes
joe biden received based on the paper
schedule and we will see if this
administration is more timely than the
trump one was
we are one minute from the scheduled
entrance of
soon to be president joe biden one
minute from the entrance
[Music]
wow do i have any guesses what trump
wrote in his letter to biden
no i assume it was written in crayon or
sharpie but i don't know the content of
it
i don't know
did you see the article that showed
melania is the most unpopular first lady
to leave office i did i talked about it
at the top of the stream and we've got a
clip
um coming up on youtube as well
trump the least popular president in the
polling era melania the least popular
first
david my boyfriend is a huge fan his
name is sam and if you said his name
he'll be surprised he's listening to
your work and i'm at home much love
nicola messina uh having me send a shout
out to sam yes sam i'm glad you're
watching
as we see committee on inaugural
ceremonies
staff representative alexandria
gordeekin
yes as we await uh as we see the for the
soon to be
uh vice president kamala harris and
we'll soon see the entrance of soon to
be president joe
biden so glad everybody is here and
joining me staff representative kate
knutson accompanying speaker of the
house of representatives
the honorable nancy pelosi and mr paul
pelosi
staff representative lindsey kerr
accompanying the honorable amy klobuchar
and mr john bessler staff representative
stephanie haeger
mucko accompanying senate majority
leader the honorable mitch mcconnell
and the honorable elaine l chao and
staff there's nothing honorable about
mitch mcconnell
disgusting display depraved obstructor
mitch mcconnell is more like it
there is the soon-to-be president joe
biden
dr jill biden did you guys know jill
biden's not a medical doctor
a lot of right wingers very focused on
that over the last few weeks
not a medical doctor
very important apparently
i know i know it's it's ridiculous could
you imagine if trump won and we got
another four years disasters
big fan of yours thanks for the
excellent show amsterdam
hey david i just signed up it's guy on
okay i apologize
[Music]
forward
uh many q anon folks uh shocked that
joe biden isn't being carried in to this
and is able to walk under his own power
i know that that
comes as a surprise to many of the
people that are
you know susceptible to certain
delusions that we've seen
and we will soon see the entrance of uh
joe biden who is just minutes
oh and it's snowing in washington d.c
wow
thanks david for all you do the no trump
left is probably blank with a sharpie
next to it
ladies and gentlemen accompanying the
president-elect the staff director of
the joint congressional committee and
inaugural ceremonies
fitsu elder iv the acting house senate
sergeant-at-arms
tim blodgett and the acting senate
sergeant-at-arms jennifer hemingway
yes
i guess if i had to guess i'd say the
note the letter that trump
left biden is an electoral map with
certain states biden one
sharpied in with a red sharpie by trump
that would be my guess as to what's in
the letter
it's more of a visual letter
thanks to daniel bowers for the sub
thanks to sean scott as well
charles hines and valentin kroll
loretta flug and koa blevins
and also a big thank you to jake
sullivan lots of great people i'm
recognizing a lot of these names
the president-elect of the united states
joseph robinette biden jr
here we go jill biden doctor oh no the
conservatives are triggered
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
greeting the former president there is
depraved lunatic brett kavanaugh
[Music]
clapping
[Music]
[Applause]
what a day
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
and we are starting
just five minutes behind schedule often
the case
in order to make sure the swearing-in
happens after noon as prescribed by the
constitution
please welcome the honorable amy
klobuchar
amy klobuchar about to clobber these
guys
vice president pence mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect members of
congress and the judicial branch
former presidents and first ladies vice
presidents
leaders from abroad and a whole bunch of
bidens
america welcome to the 59th presidential
inauguration
where in just a few moments joe biden
and kamala harris
will take their solemn oaths
this ceremony is the culmination of
244 years of a democracy
it is the moment when leaders brought to
this stage by the will of the people
promised to be faithful
to our constitution to cherish it and
defend it
it is the moment when they become as we
all
should be guardians of our country
have we become too jaded too accustomed
to the ritual
of the passing of the torch of democracy
to truly
appreciate what a blessing and a
privilege it is to witness this moment
i think not two weeks ago
when an angry violent mob staged an
insurrection
and desecrated this temple of our
democracy
right it awakened us to our
responsibilities
as americans this is the day
when our democracy picks itself up
brushes off the dust and does what
america
always does goes forward as a nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice
for all must be awkward for pence oh my
god look at my
conveyance of a sacred trust between our
leaders and our people
takes place in front of this shining
capital dome
for a reason when abraham lincoln gave
his first
inaugural address in front of this
capital the dome was only
partially constructed braced by ropes of
steel
he promised he would finish it he was
criticized for spending
funds on it during the civil war to
those critics he replied
if the people see the capital going on
it is a sign we intend the union
shall go on and it did and it will
generations of americans gave their
lives to preserve our republic in this
place
great legislation to protect civil
rights and economic security
and lead the world was debated and
crafted under this dome
now it falls on all of us not just the
two leaders we are inaugurating today
to take up the torch of our democracy
not as a weapon of political arson
but as an instrument for good
we pledge today never to take our
democracy for granted
as we celebrate its remarkable strength
we celebrate its resilience
its grit we celebrate the ordinary
people doing extraordinary things for
our nation
the doctors and nurses on the front line
of this pandemic the officers
in the capitol a new generation never
giving up hope for justice we celebrate
a new president joe biden who vows to
restore the soul of america and cross
the river of our divides to a higher
plane
and we celebrate our first
african-american first
asian american and first woman vice
president kamala harris
who stands on the shoulders of so many
on this platform who have forged the way
to this day when she takes the oath of
office
little girls and boys across the world
will know that anything
and everything is possible and in the
end
that is america our democracy
a country of so much good and today
on these capital steps and before
this glorious field of flags we
rededicate
ourselves to its cause
thank you can you imagine that just
during this we had to ban someone from
twitch for mandatory vaccination
conspiracy theories
can you imagine come on guys so many
others to make
this ceremony possible my friend and the
chair of the inaugural committee
missouri senator
roy blunt
a lot of band hammers being dropped
you do it because you have to not
because we want to
well i should have known when senator
klobuchar got involved at least there'd
be a touch of snow
up here this morning of all the things
we'd considered
i don't think snow was on my agenda
until i walked out the door
a moment ago but thank you senator
klobuchar and thanks to the other
members
of the joint congressional committee on
the inauguration as we
officially begin the 59th inaugural
ceremony
i also want to thank the joint committee
staff and our partners particularly our
security partners
for the they the way they've dealt with
unprecedented
circumstances when i chaired the
inauguration four years ago i shared
president reagan's
1981 description of this event as
commonplace
and miraculous commonplace because we've
done it
every four years since 1789
miraculous because we've done it every
four years
since 1789. americans have celebrated
this moment during war
during depression and now during
pandemic
once again all three branches of our
government come together as the
constitution envisions
once again we renew our commitment
to our determined democracy forging a
more perfect union
that theme for this inauguration our
determined
democracy forging a more perfect union
was announced by the joint committee
before the election
with the belief that the united states
can only fulfill its promise
and set an example for others if we are
always working
to be better than we have been the
constitution established that determined
democracy with its first three words
declaring the people as the source of
the government
the articles of confederation hadn't
done that the magna carta hadn't done
that
only the constitution says the
government exists
because the people are the source of the
reason
it exists they immediately followed
those first three words
with the words to form a more perfect
union
the founders did not say to form a
perfect union
they did not claim that in our new
country nothing would need to be
improved fortunately they understood
that
always working to be better would be the
hallmark
of a great democracy the freedoms we
have today
the nation we have today
is not here just because it happened
and they aren't complete a great
democracy working through the successes
and failures of our history striving to
be better than it had been
and we are more than we have been and we
are
less than we hope to be the assault on
our capital at this very place just two
weeks ago
incited by many of these clowns designed
to balance and check itself
is both fragile and resilient
during the last year the pandemic
challenged our free and open society and
called for extraordinary determination
and sacrifice and still challenges us
today
meeting that challenge head on have been
and our health care workers scientists
first responders essential frontline
workers
and so many others we depend on in so
many ways
today we come to this moment people all
over the world
as we're here are watching and we'll
watch what we do here
our government comes together the
congress and the courts join the
transition
of executive responsibility one
political party more pleased today
and on every inaugural day than the
other
but this is not a moment of division
it's a moment of unification
a new administration begins and brings
with it
a new beginning and with that our great
national debate goes forward
and a determined democracy will continue
to be
essential in pursuit of a more perfect
union and a better future
for all americans what a privilege for
me to join you
today thank you for people asking why
this is the 59th inauguration but not
the 46th many presidents got two terms
so they had two inaugurations
of the president-elect and his family
father leo o'donovan
to lead us in an invocation please stand
if you are able and remain standing for
the national anthem
and the pledge to our flag i'm not a big
fan of the religious components but we
are carrying the entire inauguration
ceremony
and so we
thank
will
gracious and merciful god
at this sacred time we come before you
in need
indeed on our knees
but we come still more with hope and
with our eyes raised anew
to the vision of a more perfect union in
our land
a union of all our citizens to promote
the general welfare
and secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves
and our posterity we are a people
of many races creeds and colors
national backgrounds cultures and styles
now far more numerous and on land much
vaster
than when archbishop john carroll wrote
his prayer
for the inauguration of george
washington 232
years ago archbishop
carol prayed that you o creator of all
would assist with your holy spirit of
counsel and fortitude
the president of these united states
that his administration may be conducted
in righteousness
and be eminently useful to your people
today we confess our past failures to
live
according to our vision of equality
inclusion and freedom for all
yet we resolutely commit still more now
to renewing the vision
to caring for one another in word and
deed
especially the least fortunate among us
and so becoming a light for the world
there is a power in each and every one
of us that lives
by turning to every other one of us a
trust
of the spirit to cherish and care and
stand by others
and above all those most in need
it is called love and its path
is to give ever more of itself
today it is called american
patriotism born not of power and
privilege
but of care for the common good
with malice toward none and with charity
for all for our new president
we beg of you the wisdom solomon sought
when he knelt before you and prayed for
an understanding heart
so that i can govern your people and
know the difference
between right and wrong we trust in the
counsel of the letter of james
if any of you lacks wisdom you should
ask
god who gives generously to all without
finding fault
and it will be given to you
pope francis has reminded us how
important it is
to dream together
by ourselves he wrote we risk seeing
mirages
things that are not there dreams on the
other hand
are built together
be with us holy mystery of love
as we dream together
help us under our new president to
reconcile the people of our land restore
our dream and invest it with peace and
justice
and the joy that is the overflow
of love to the glory of your name
forever amen
okay not a part of the ceremony i find
necessary but
all right
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the presentation of our
national colors by the armed forces
color guard
the singing of our national anthem and
for the pledge of allegiance
[Music]
down to the last half hour
biden will be eligible for swearing in
in 25 minutes and it will probably
happen in about a half hour
a lot of messages from folks saying this
should be a secular event i agree
i don't expect we will see ymca played
[Music]
no
[Music]
now consider that there are still at
this moment people who think
something will happen between now and 12
1205 eastern
that will lead to biden being imprisoned
here for the singing of our national
anthem
accompanied by the president's own
united states marine band
please welcome lady gaga
[Applause]
very strong event
gotta have a gold microphone obviously
a gilded mic
oh say can you
see by the dawn's early
light
[Music]
broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
me
[Music]
was still there
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow lady gaga delivering the national
anthem
a pledge of allegiance to the flag
coming soon
and then we will be very close to the
inauguration of joe biden
and there goes lady gaga at one point
you could see mike pence in the
background
welcome from the city of south fulton
georgia fire and rescue department
president of the international
association of firefighters
local 3920 fire captain andrea m hall
for the reciting of the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance
to the flag of the united states
of america and to the republic
for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
[Music]
[Applause]
what you are all about to be part of
america
is a historic moment of firsts and
history to administer
the oath to our first african-american
our first asian-american and our first
woman
vice president kamala harris it is my
great privilege to welcome to the
inaugural stage
the first latina to ever serve on the
supreme court
of the united states of america justice
sonia
sotomayor
ladies and gentlemen remain standing for
the oath of office followed by musical
honors
we are moments from vice president
kamala harris
mitch mcconnell in the background
disgusted repeat after me
i kamala davey harrison
oh my god
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same that i take this
obligation
freely that i take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge
that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office
on which i am about to enter the duties
of the office
upon which i am about to enter so help
me god
so help me god
kamala harris now the vice president of
the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
queuing on accounts everywhere folding
and being canceled as people don't
understand she was supposed to be in
prison
biden was supposed to be in prison what
is happening
unable to cope
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
please welcome jennifer lopez to perform
this land as your land
and america the beautiful accompanied by
members of the president's own united
states marine band
wow
what a day
if you're just joining us trump has 15
minutes left as president
[Music]
this land is your land
this land is my land
from california
to the new york islands
from the redwood forest
to the gulf stream waters
this land was made for you
and me as i went walking
down that ribbon of highway
i saw about me adding this skyway
i saw below me
at golden valley
this land was made for you and
me
[Music]
this land was made for you and me
this land was made for you and
me you and me
[Music]
america
god shed his grace on thee
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right this land was
made for you and
[Music]
me
all right there is jennifer lopez at
this exact moment
the white house is being sprayed down
and deep
cleaned to remove not only the stink but
the germs of the trump administration
that joe biden will soon be
inhabiting the sun is shining and mr
president-elect this is the first
inauguration
in the history of america where j-lo was
the warm-up act for chief justice
roberts
uh with that that's not bad actually my
distinct honor
to introduce the chief justice of the
supreme court of the united states
john roberts to administer the
presidential oath
to the next president of the united
states
joseph r biden
do you think there are trumpists who
will say this is invalid because it's
happening before noon
like i i i'm worried that actually there
will be trumpets who say that
please raise your right hand and here we
go
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability to
the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states constitution of the united
states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Applause]
joe biden now president of the united
states
the national nightmare oh i was
expecting macho man to play
um the national nightmare of four years
of trump is officially over
[Music]
president joe biden is now president
donald trump is now a
former president
we will hear momentarily from joe biden
a speech expected to last 20 to 30
minutes
wow and it will be right to work
joe biden expected to sign a number of
executive orders we're expecting a press
briefing at 7 pm this is a work day
and rightly so there is really no time
to waste
quite quite the opposite in fact
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
pence despondent
[Music]
oh my goodness i don't even know where
that came from that was weird
that was the song for kamala oh boy
oh man what a day
do people want that song until it starts
[Music]
kind of makes sense actually
democrat kamala okay anyway my fellow
americans
a moment we have all been waiting for
i'll say it is now my great privilege
and high honor to be the first person
to officially introduce the 46th
president of the united states joseph
r biden jr
president joe biden
will be addressing the country for the
first time as
president
everything has been disinfected
wow chief justice roberts
vice president harris right
speaker pelosi leader schumer
mr mcconnell vice president pence
my distinguished guests my fellow
americans
this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renewal and resolve through a
crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile and at this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed
just barely but yes on this hallowed
ground where just a few
days ago violence sought to shake the
capital's very foundation
we come together as one nation under god
indivisible to carry out the peaceful
transfer of power as we have for more
than two centuries
as we look ahead in our uniquely
american way
restless bold optimistic
and set our sights on the nation we know
we can be
and we must be i thank my predecessors
of both parties
for their presence here today i thank
them from the bottom of my heart
not trump
and i know the resilience of our
constitution
and the strength the strength of our
nation
as does president carter who i spoke
with last night who cannot be with us
today
but whom we salute for his lifetime in
service
i've just taken the sacred oath each of
those patriots
have taken the oath first sworn
by george washington but the american
story
depends not on any one of us not on some
of us
but on all of us on we
the people who seek a more perfect union
this is a great nation we are good
people and over the centuries through
storm and strife
in peace and in war we've come so far
but we still have far to go
we'll press forward with speed and
urgency for we have much to do
in this winter of peril and significant
possibilities
much to repair much to restore
much to heal much to build and much to
gain
hopefully he doesn't even say the word
trump few people in our nation's history
have been more challenged or found a
time more challenging
or difficult than the time we're in now
once in a century virus that silently
stalks the country
has taken as many lives in one year
as america lost in all of world
war ii millions of jobs have been lost
hundreds of thousands of businesses
closed
a cry for racial justice some 400 years
in the making
moves us the dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer
[Applause]
a cry for survival comes from planet
itself
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now a rise of
political extremism
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
to overcome these challenges to restore
the soul and secure the future of
america
requires so much more than words
it requires the most elusive of all
things in a democracy
unity unity
in another january on new year's day in
1863
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause
uniting to fight the foes we face
anger resentment and hatred extremism
lawlessness violence disease
joblessness and hopelessness with unity
we can do great things important things
we can right wrongs we can put people to
work in good jobs we can teach our
children
in safe schools we can overcome the
deadly virus
we can reward reward work and rebuild
the middle class and make health care
secure for all
we can deliver racial justice and we can
make america once again
the leading force for good in the world
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart
the battle is perennial and victory is
never assured
through civil war the great depression
world war 9 11
through struggle sacrifice and setbacks
our better angels
have always prevailed
in each of these moments enough of us
enough of us
have come together to carry all of us
forward
and we can do that now history
faith and reason show the way
the way of unity we can see each other
not as adversaries but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces stop the shouting and
lower the temperature
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury no progress
only exhausting outrage no nation
only a state of chaos this is our
historic moment
of crisis and challenge and unity
is the path forward and we must meet
this moment
as the united states of america
if we do that i guarantee you we will
not fail
we have never ever ever ever failed in
america
we've acted together and so today
at this time in this place let's start
afresh
all of us let's begin to listen to one
another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another politics
doesn't have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in his path
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause for total war
and we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufactured
not something pence can credibly clap
for and he's not clapping
my fellow americans we have to be
different than this
america has to be better than this and i
believe america is so much better than
this just look around
here we stand in the shadow of the
capital dome
as was mentioned earlier completed amid
the civil war
when the union itself was literally
hanging in the balance
yet we endured we prevailed
here we stand looking out on the great
mall
where dr king spoke of his dream
here we stand we're 108 years ago
at another inaugural thousands of
protesters tried to block
brave women marching for the right to
vote
and today we mark the swearing-in of the
first woman in american history
elected to national office vice
president kamala harris
don't tell me things can't change
here we stand across the potomac from
arlington cemetery
where heroes who gave the last full
measure of devotion
rest in eternal peace and here we stand
just days after a riotous mob thought
they could use violence to silence the
will of the people
to stop the work of our democracy to
drive us from this sacred ground
it did not happen it will never happen
not today not tomorrow not ever
not ever
does pence even clap for that our
campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
and if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
the right to dissent peaceably then the
guard rails of our republic is perhaps
this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to this
union
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and i promise you i will fight as hard
for those who did not support me
as for those who did
many centuries ago saint augustine
a saint of my church wrote that a people
was a multitude
defined by the common objects of their
love
defined by the common objects of their
love
what are the common objects we as
americans love
that define us as americans i think we
know
opportunity security
liberty dignity respect honor
and yes the truth
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies told for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans and especially
as leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation bill clinton's
statement
and defeat the lies look
i understand that many of my fellow
americans view the future
with fear and trepidation i understand
they worry about their jobs
i understand like my dad they lay a bed
staring at the
night staring at the ceiling wondering
can i keep my health care
can i pay my mortgage thinking about
their families
about what comes next i promise you i
get
but the answer is not to turn inward to
retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
if we show a little tolerance and
humility
and if we're willing to stand in the
other person's shoes as my mom would say
just for a moment stand in their shoes
because here's the thing about life
there's no accounting for what fate will
deal you
some days when you need a hand
there are other days when we're called
to lend a hand
that's how it has to be it's what we do
for one another
and if we are this way our country will
be stronger
more prosperous more ready for the
future
and we can still disagree my fellow
americans
and the work ahead of us we're going to
need each other
we need all our strength to preser to
persevere
through this dark winter we're entering
what may be the toughest and deadliest
period of the virus
we must set aside politics and finally
face this pandemic
as one nation
one nation and i promise you this
as the bible says weeping may endure for
a night
but joy cometh in the morning we will
get through this together together
look folks all my colleagues i serve
with
in the house and the senate up here
we all understand the world is watching
watching all of us today so here's my
message to those beyond our borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
glad he's mentioning that not to meet
yesterday's challenges
but today's and tomorrow's challenges
awkward for pence
and will lead not merely by the example
of our power but by the power of our
example
we'll be a strong and trusted partner
for peace
progress and security
look you all know we've been through so
much in this nation
and my first act as president i'd like
to ask you to join me
in a moment of silent prayer remember
all
those who have lost in this past year to
the pandemic wow
those four hundred thousand not
something trump did
moms dads husbands wives sons daughters
friends neighbors and co-workers we'll
honor them
by becoming the people and the nation we
know we
can and should be so i ask you
let's say a silent prayer for those
who've lost their lives and those left
behind
and for our country
more recognition for those 400 000
than what we saw sincerely
from trump the entire time this is a
time of testing
we face an attack under democracy and on
truth
a raging virus growing inequity
the sting of systemic racism a climate
in crisis
america's role in the world any one of
these would be enough to challenge us
in profound ways but the fact is
we face them all at once
presenting this nation with the one of
the greatest responsibilities we've had
now we're going to be tested are we
going to step up
all of us it's time for boldness
for there's so much to do and this
is certain i promise you
we will be judged you and i
by how we resolve these cascading crises
of our era
we will rise to the occasion is the
question will we master
this rare and difficult hour when we
meet our obligations and pass along
a new and better world to our children i
believe we must i'm sure you do as well
i believe we will and when we do
we'll write the next great chapter in
the history of the united states of
america the american story
a story that might sound something like
a song that means a lot to me
it's called american anthem
there's one verse that stands out
at least for me and it goes like this
the work and prayers of century have
brought us to this day
what shall be our legacy what will our
children say
let me know in my heart when my days are
through
america america i gave my best to you
let's add let's us add our own work and
prayers
to the unfolding story of our great
nation
if we do this then when our days are
through
our children and our children's children
will save us
they gave their best they did their duty
they healed the broken land
my fellow americans i closed the day
where i began
with the sacred oath before god and all
of you
i give you my word i will always level
with you
i will defend the constitution i'll
defend our democracy
i'll defend america and i'll give
all all of you keep
everything you i do in your service
thinking not of power but of
possibilities not a personal interest
but the public good and together we
shall write an american story
of hope not fear of unity not division
of light
not darkness a story of decency and
dignity
love and healing greatness and goodness
may this be the story that guides us the
story that inspires us
and the story that tells ages yet to
come
that we answer the call of history we
met the moment
democracy and hope truth and justice
did not die in our watch but thrive
that america secured liberty at home and
stood once again as a beacon to the
world
that is what we owe our forebears one
another
and generation to follow so
with purpose and resolve we turn to
those
tasks of our time sustained by
faith driven by conviction and devoted
to one another and the country we love
with all our hearts may god bless
america
and may god protect our troops thank you
america
and with that we are past the stroke of
noon eastern time
and there is a new president joe biden
is now the president of the united
states
kamala harris now the vice president of
the united states
trump is done trump is gone
uh trump delivering some screeds this
morning on his way
to palm beach florida and opting not to
even stick around
not to not to even stick around some of
the things mentioned by biden
really put please be seated pence in
sort of a weird position talking about
the riot that was his supporters talking
about misinformation that's his
administration that was putting it out
there
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
garth brooks to perform
amazing grace garth brooks of course
declined to perform for trump saying it
was a scheduling conflict
and that this is not political for him
it was merely a scheduling conflict
that prevented him from doing this four
years ago
do we believe that i don't know
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
how sweet the
sound then
saved a wretch
like me
i was worse
strong secret services see
[Music]
when we've been
there ten thousand
[Music]
the sun
we've known
days to sing
god's praise
then when we
first begun
if i ask you to sing this last verse
with me not just the people here
but the people at home at work as one
united
may sing grace
how sweet the
sound that saved
her like me
hence not singing i
once was lost
but now
was blind but
now i see man
and there he goes garth brooks
i'm confused because biden was going to
cancel religion but there's been a lot
of references to god and prayers here
hugging everyone with no mask okay
[Music]
test it i'm sure right
[Applause]
hard not to be reminded of president
obama's singing that same song at the
mother emanuel
church right
a song that in our culture is as close
to both poetry and prayer
as you could possibly come and we're
going to finish with those two things
let me introduce
amanda gorman our nation's first
ever national poet laureate
mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhoff americans and
the world when day comes we
ask ourselves where can we find light in
this
never-ending shade the loss
we carry a sea we must wade we've braved
the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is isn't always just
is and yet the dawn is hours before
we knew it somehow we do it somehow
we've
weathered and witnessed a nation
that isn't broken but simply
unfinished we the successors of a
country
and the time where a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president only to
find herself
reciting for one and yes we are
far from polished far from pristine but
that doesn't mean we are
striving to form a union that is perfect
we
are striving to forge our union with
purpose to compose a country committed
to all cultures colors characters
and conditions of man and so we lift our
gazes not to what stands
between us but what stands before us
we close the divide because we know to
put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we lay down our arms so we can reach
out our arms to one another we seek harm
to none
and harmony for all let the globe if
nothing else
say this is true that even as we grieved
we grew that even as we hurt we hoped
that
even as we tired we tried that we'll
forever be
tied together victorious not because we
will never again
no defeat but because we will never
again sow division
scripture tells us to envision that
everyone shall sit
under their own vine and fig tree and no
one shall make them
afraid if we're to live up to our own
time
then victory won't lie in the blade but
in all the bridges
we've made that is the promise to glade
the
hill we climb if only we dare it because
being american is more than a pride
we inherit it's the past we step into
and how we repair it we've seen a forest
that would
shatter our nation rather than share it
would destroy our country if it meant
delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it could never
be permanently defeated in this
truth in this faith we trust for while
we have our
eyes on the future history has its eyes
on us this is the era of just
redemption we feared it at its inception
we did not feel prepared
to be the heirs of such a terrifying
hour but within it we found
the power to author a new chapter to
offer hope
and laughter to ourselves so while
once we asked how could we possibly
prevail
over catastrophe now we
assert how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us we will not
march back to
what was but move to what shall be a
country that is bruised but whole
benevolent but bold fierce and free
we will not be turned around or
interrupted by
intimidation because we know our
inaction
and inertia will be the inheritance of
the next generation our blenders
become their burdens but one thing is
certain
if we merge mercy with might
into might with rights then love
becomes our legacy and change
our children's birthright so let us
leave behind a country better than one
we were left with
every breath from our bronze pounded
chest we will raise this wounded world
into a wondrous one we will rise from
the gold-limbed hills
of the west we will rise from the wind
swept northeast where our forefathers
first realized revolution we will
rise from the lake rim cities of the
midwestern states we will rise from the
sun baked south we will
rebuild reconcile and recover and every
known nook
of our nation in every corner called our
country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge
battered and beautiful when day comes we
step
out of the shade a flame and unafraid
the new dawn blooms
as we free it for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only we're brave enough to be it
very very impressive
thank you amanda gorman now for our
benediction i'm pleased to introduce
reverend dr sylvester beeman the pastor
of the bethel
african methodist episcopal church in
wilmington delaware
a friend of president biden for 30 years
the white house website reflects the
current president of the united states
very quickly changed over
i would have closed with amanda gorman
myself but
you know
as a nation and people of faith gathered
in this historical moment
let us unite in prayer
god we gather under the beauty of your
holiness
and the holiness of your beauty we seek
your face
your smile your warm embrace
we petition you once more in this
celebration
we pray for divine favor upon our
president
joseph r biden and our first lady
dr jill biden and their family
we further asked that you would extend
the same
favor upon our vice president
kamala d harris and our second gentleman
doug imhoff and their family
more than ever more than ever
they in our nation need you
we need you for in you we discover our
common humanity
in our common humanity we will seek out
the wounded
and bind their wounds we will seek
healing for those who are sick
and diseased we will mourn
our dead we will befriend the lonely the
least
and the left out we will share our
abundance with those who are hungry
we will do justly to the oppressed
acknowledge
sin and seek forgiveness
thus grasping reconciliation in
discovering our
humanity we will seek the good
in and for all our neighbors
we will love the unlovable remove the
stigma of the so-called
we will care for our most vulnerable our
children
the elderly emotionally challenged and
the poor
we will seek rehabilitation beyond
correction
we'll extend opportunities to those
locked out of
opportunity we will make friends
of our enemies we will make friends
of our enemies people your people
shall no longer raise up weapons against
one another
we will rather use our resources for the
national good and become a beacon of
life
and good will to the world and neither
shall we
learn hatred anymore
we'll lie down in peace and not make our
neighbors afraid
in you oh god we discover our humanity
in our humanity we discover our
commonness
beyond the difference of color creed
origin
political party ideology geography
and personal preferences will become
greater stewards of your environment
preserving the land reaping from it a
sustainable harvest
and securing its wonder and
miracle-giving power
for generations to come this is
our benediction that from
these hallowed grounds
where slaves labor to build this shrine
and citadel
to liberty and democracy let us all
acknowledge
from the indigenous native american
to those who recently received their
citizenship
from the african-american to those whose
four parents came
from europe and every corner of the
globe
from the wealthy to those struggling to
make it
from every human being regardless of
their choices
that this is our country
as such teachers oh god as such
teach us oh god to live in it
loving it be healed in it
and reconcile to one another in it
lest we miss kingdom's goal
to your glory majesty
dominion and power forever
hallelujah glory
hallelujah and the strong name of our
collective faith
amen
please remain standing as the armed
forces color guard retires our national
colors
[Applause]
that's a surprise just kidding i got you
guys some of you guys thought it was
happening right
did i get anybody someone fell for it
i'm sure
[Music]
some people fell for it beautiful
oh that was perfect can somebody clip
that please
[Music]
space force flag recedes
[Music]
clip it
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
and remain in your seats while the
president and official party depart the
platform
the president your ushers will release
your section in an organized manner
not the president-elect national march
the stars and stripes forever
the president
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a day so there is a very very long
day ahead of us
um i'm gonna be back with people later
once we're done with this stream which
is not yet i'm gonna be back with with
you guys later because there
joe biden's actually at five o'clock
signing a bunch of executive orders
we'll see what's on the list he will
hope to on day one
literally on day one undo some of the
damage done by donald trump that's
around five today
at seven we're go whoa elaine chow
almost taking a digger there that was
close
um we are going to then at 7 pm already
get our first
press briefing of the administration
from gen sackey i predict it will be
dramatically different than
what we saw from kaylee mcinanni who of
course deserves to never work again
and then 8 48 p.m eastern time we're
expecting to hear
from joe biden and
kamala harris and then we will see joe
biden and jill biden
that's dr jill biden remember on the
blue room balcony i believe it's called
so it's really going to be quite a day
quite a day with with a lot a lot a lot
happening
and i'm i mean it's weird but i'm very
curious about
how different the press briefing is
going to look tonight
kamala harris and the second gentleman
doug imhoff exiting
[Music]
here is joe biden walking through the
capitol and exiting
i think it's pretty clear to say this
guy has become biden's lead secret
service agent
pretty pretty clear thank you
and uh a real there will have to be some
kind of uh reckoning
from the uh oh no some people thought
that lil
pump was performing but no no no no no
lil pump not performing uh today
um what happens to the republican party
now
losing everything uh losing the respect
of the u.s globally
losing the house of representatives in
2018 losing the senate in 2020 losing
the presidential election
in 2020. so a lot of losses
[Music]
joe biden continuing to exit the capitol
[Music]
yeah i don't even know who lil pump is
but i'm pretty sure trump referred to
him as
lil thank pimp
thank you
the inauguration going off without
incident i'm sure
sure we will later learn about whether
there were attempts to breach security
but going out without incident for the
time being
and that is a very very important thing
many fears
many many fears thanks to music man for
gifting 25 subscriptions i really
appreciate that
and now slowly but surely folks will
begin to file out we see former
president barack obama there talking to
a
number of different people
and slowly they will all exit
donald trump's name not even mentioned
once during joe biden's speech and i
think that's a good thing
uh listen he wasn't there he wasn't
missed
why even mention his name and
mike pence at some key moments
conspicuously not clapping
conspicuously not clapping and i think
that that's uh
notable and why would he why would he
when they say the riots those were the
riots incited by his followers
sorry the riots carried out by his
followers when they say stopping
disinformation it's disinformation
perpetuated by
uh media supportive of him and by his
own administration
so uh the absolutely correct
thanks kai dizzle for gifting 10 subs on
twitch i appreciate that as well
um yeah i will be back with more streams
today so make sure that you're
subscribed on youtube and following on
twitch because it's all free this is
free just follow and then you'll be
notified of future streams
um we're going to put together a
schedule soon i've got a couple other
things to record for
today's show tomorrow's show getting a
jump on some things big day
but very important stuff so i'm going to
be back back with you guys later we will
open some phone lines
and we're going to have a lot of things
happening many many things happening
what an exciting day what an exciting
day
so on twitch let's raid our friend
levy rosman on gotham chess we're going
to be wrapping
this stream an historic day
and we are going to be back with you um
in a few hours all right so thanks to
everybody who joined me
subscribe on youtube
follow on twitch and i'll be before you
know it we're gonna have another stream
you